hey you guys flickers of fear time this
is my little movie review show
so the movie we're going to be talking
about today uh came out in 2016 and is
called under the shadow uh it's actually
on netflix at the moment and has been
for quite a long time
this was another movie that
i saw
quite a long time ago i think i saw it
back in 2017 i want to say and i really
really loved it so it was one that i
wanted to revisit for the show you know
to see if it's still held up like this
many years later and stuff like that and
i'm happy to report that it absolutely
does and i will say too that i'm glad
that for whatever reason like the first
time i watched this and i think i even
mentioned this because i wrote this i
wrote about it on my blog a long time
ago but it's like the first time i
watched it i watched the dubbed version
because i guess back then i didn't
realize that you could probably change
it like back to
its you know original language and watch
it subtitled which i always prefer and i
guess i didn't know that you could do
that so i ended up watching it dubbed
and it really kind of like
you know i got used to it after a while
but it did kind of annoy me so
this time i was at least smart enough to
be like oh hey gonna turn that english
dubbing off i'm gonna have like the
regular the regular language soundtrack
and i'll just you know read the english
subtitles i'm fine with that so i can
hear everybody's real voices like i said
other than giallo movies i'll give them
a pass but it's like generally i really
do not like dubbing because it's just
too distracting it just takes me out of
the movie if
if i know that that's like not what the
actual actors voices sound like so you
know so i'm glad that i got to watch it
in its original language the way i
probably should have watched it the
first time around
so now if you know anything about this
movie
i don't know if you guys have uh seen it
but this was actually the directorial
debut
of babak and vari
now he is a british-based filmmaker
although he was born in iran he actually
left iran when he was a teenager
and uh he also did he directed back in i
think it was 2018 or 2019 he directed
the movie wounds which is actually quite
a good film if you're into like weird
like surrealist [ __ ] i thought it's
really weird because i could have sworn
that i had reviewed that movie you know
it lived on the matinee show or on here
or something like that but i looked back
and i never did i knew i had done the
book i did actually do the uh the book
by nathan balengrod which is like a
short story collection so maybe that's
what i was thinking of but i know i
watched the movie so it's like i don't
know why i didn't do the movie as well
but whatever but so this was actually um
that was directed the movie was directed
by babak and vary as well but this was
actually his first one
and i have to say as much as i liked
wounds um you know that was a you know
it was an adaptation of someone else's
work whereas this one i think
it uh seemed like a lot more personal
film for him because it was set uh
during the iran iraq war uh in the 1980s
like i think it was set in 1988 uh which
was right when he was a kid and you know
the cultural revolution all that kind of
stuff so he remembered a lot of the
stuff
so he brought like a lot of his own uh
sort of
personal experience to the story now if
you
look at a pretty much every review of
this movie that i've read and i've read
a [ __ ] ton of them from all over the
place pretty much every one of them will
compare it usually favorably to the
babadook now
i will say that there are some
similarities
in the sense that
it's very focused on
the relationship between a mother and a
child
and in the sense that it's a
supernatural story but it's also like a
metaphorical story
but i will say as much as i really liked
the babadook i kind of feel like that's
maybe where the similarities end this
one kind of has i feel like the babadook
is more like
a personal story like between the mom
and the sun and like you know the grief
and everything like that this one has a
lot more is a lot you know it yes it's
about the relationship between the
mother and the daughter but it's also
about something much larger like it's a
much like a sociocultural
type of thing like the [ __ ] that was
going on uh you know in iran at that
time and uh you know this the sharia law
coming down so i kind of feel like that
was
so this one has like a lot more social
commentary but that said
you can enjoy it just as like a creepy
ghost story it's still metaphorical but
it's still pretty plainly supernatural
as well i don't think that it has
quite the same thing as the babadook had
where it was just kind of like you know
the monster wasn't really
real in any sense this one it definitely
does seem like the monster is real but
she could read it either way and i will
say it like i said as much as i like the
baba joke i think i liked this one a
little bit better
just because i don't know if i found it
creepier i don't know there was just
like something about it that i really
liked and it was kind of like i was
watching something the other day
something that was called uh
compounded horror where it's like and i
think i've talked about this before
where you know you're in this kind of
like shitty situation and then oh and by
the way like this shitty thing happens
this shitty thing happens and then oh by
the way there's also you know monsters i
think i was talking about it in
regards to the descent where you know
they're lost they're claustrophobic you
know they're you know they don't know
where they are and [ __ ] like that and oh
by the way there
are people eating monsters down there so
this is kind of like the same thing
so the story that we have this is set in
uh tehran in 1988 and our main character
is a young woman named shide
and she was actually in uh medical
school but then during the cultural
revolution because she was at the
university and she was involved in
leftist politics they will not allow her
to continue her medical studies so they
uh generally kick her out of college uh
this understandably makes her very
resentful
um she
wanted to be a doctor very badly her
mother was a doctor and she wanted to
carry that on
so she gets a little pissed off about it
now her husband irraj uh is a doctor
already and at some point pretty early
on in the movie
he gets called off to uh the front lines
because like they call this uh i think
it was called the war between the cities
where uh iraq started like bombing
tehran uh pretty much all the time so it
was like air raids and stuff
so he gets sent away they tell him if
you don't go to the front lines you know
you're gonna lose your license to
practice so he's like okay well i have
to go
now shide is kind of like like i said
she um was a very very modern woman she
was studying to be a doctor um you know
she
she works out to her jane fonda
videotape she's got like all this stuff
so
you know when
when sharia law starts coming in she's
really really not down with it um she's
still got a vcr which you're not
supposed to have she's really like
resentful
of all these new uh you know laws coming
to you know she can't just not allow to
drive anymore she's you know so
basically she's kind of like stuck in
the apartment now looking after her and
her husband's daughter dorsa
now
pretty much the first half of the movie
is almost kind of like
a domestic drama because
and i really like the character of shide
who's played by an actress named nargis
rashidi she's like fantastic in this and
i love that
she's not
always a likable character and i think
that was kind of like cool that they
made her like that but everything that
she does
you can understand like why if you were
in the same situation that she was in
you would probably act like that too
because like i said she gets real real
[ __ ] snippy
when you know her husband is like you
know oh maybe this is all for the best
and now you can stay home and take care
of our kid with the implication being
that you weren't going to be a good
mother before because you were too busy
trying to be a doctor and all this other
kind of stuff so you know he's a little
condescending
and then the fact that now she's
essentially stuck in her apartment
because she's not really you know like i
said she's not allowed to drive anymore
and stuff like that so
she's kind of stuck here with the kid
and it's like she loves her daughter but
she wanted more you know out of her life
and she's also afraid too that like the
more this goes on like it's going to
affect her daughter as well obviously
like when she gets to be a woman
so there's that kind of whole thing
going on too so now she's stuck in the
apartment with dorsa she gets like like
i said a little snappy with her
sometimes uh you know and not only that
because you know they have a little bit
of tension going on she has a lot of
personal resentment but also because the
city's being bombed uh you know there's
air-raid sirens they have to run down to
the basement [ __ ] like that and then as
the movie goes on other residents of the
building are starting to get the [ __ ]
out of there you know what i mean
now
iraj before he leaves he basically tells
shide he's like look why don't you leave
the city take dorsa to my parents house
it's like at least she'll have a support
network but she is uh she is very
stubborn and she's like no we'll be fine
here you know this is our home um you
know they're not gonna drive me out so
like i said it's not the smartest
decision but you can see why she does it
because she's just like very stubborn
she's very independent and she's very
resentful that her independence is
slowly being frittered away
and so she's trying to like make a stand
so she's in this building like i said
the neighbors keep leaving now at some
point
between all of this
uh there's a little boy that moves into
the apartment with another family like
neighbors of theirs his parents were
killed in the bombing like in another
city and his name is mehdi and he's
supposedly mute uh you know and has been
since his parents were dead because of
the trauma
but dorsa uh she day's little girl
says um mehdi told me that there is an
evil gin in this like haunting this
building
and he gave me this little thing like to
protect myself i think it was like a
little ball like made of cat fur or
something like that but it was supposed
to like protect her from it now she day
is like very much uh you know she's very
hard-headed she's very into science
she's just kind of like look this gin
they're not real it's you know it's all
imagination so she just like throws this
thing away because she doesn't like
she's like what the [ __ ] is this this is
like a thing of cat fur uh but dorsa
also has this little doll named kimia
which her dog which her dad gave her
and kimia is also kind of like
it comes to almost be sort of like a
totem like she believes that it protects
her from the gin
now there's a lot of conflict because
dorsa
starts to get kind of sick like she
develops this fever that won't go away
she's never hungry she doesn't really
want to eat you know she's just got all
these [ __ ] problems and she's like
you know telling her mom
that she's seeing this woman
in the building in the apartment uh but
at first she doesn't see her so she
takes dorsa to the doctor and she's like
look i can't find anything wrong with
her maybe it's just stress you know
because maybe you know maybe you should
get the [ __ ] out of the city like most
people are doing because you know we're
getting bombed to [ __ ] and all this
other stuff
and then it ends up happening that a
missile actually does hit their
apartment complex but it doesn't go off
so there's like this huge [ __ ]
missile
sitting in like you know comes through
the ceiling or whatever and there's also
a kind of thing where one of their
neighbors is like an older guy and when
the mess when the missile comes through
he has a heart attack and since shiday
was in
medical school like the neighbors asked
her to help and she tries to help him
but he dies anyway so then she also
feels guilty that you know all i had all
this knowledge and it couldn't save him
so she has that going on as well so like
i said it's not a good situation for
anybody so after the missile bus through
that's pretty much the last straw for
like most of the other residents they're
just like yeah we just gotta get the
hell out of here but again sheeta will
not go
now
at some point she starts to see
this
apparition as well uh which supposedly
is a gin now the thing about it though
it's like it's really cool i really like
the way that he did
the ghost in this one it's essentially
like a ghost but it's like wearing a
like a chad or you know like the long
you know just people like burqa type of
thing it's wearing one of those but the
thing that the gin does
is it essentially talks to dorsa the
little girl like she's her friend and
basically says you know your mom sucks
like she's not a good mother she's
always like yelling and irritated with
you and it's like i would be a much
better mother than she would and it's
like all this other kind of stuff and
then like creepy [ __ ] starts happening
around the apartment like doris's doll
kimia disappears and doris is just like
flipping out she can't like [ __ ] deal
with it you know things go missing like
uh she day's jane fonda workout tape
which is which she's not supposed to
have but she's kind of like just always
like constantly doing aerobics almost
like that's
it's like a way of relieving stress i
guess but that like ends up it goes
missing and then it ends up like in the
garbage like with it all torn out she
blames dorsa
and so they start so it's almost kind of
like the gin is like working them
against one another like saying oh you
know you took my doll you took my
workout tape you did this that and the
other because at first like i said she
obviously doesn't believe that there's a
evil gin like a ghost in the [ __ ]
apartment building but then like i said
after a while
she starts to see it herself and uh
eventually kind of starts to believe in
it there's also a lot of kind of
symbolic stuff about because like i said
after the missile like crashes through
the roof of the building i don't
remember what floor they're on i think
it's only like the second or third but
it's just like a cup like i think it's
the fourth floor up so it's like a floor
up from them so like there's some cracks
in the ceiling and she just like is
basically like trying to fix it with
like masking tape and stuff and then at
one point like the doll uh dorsal's doll
kimia like reappears but she's all torn
up and then you know she is like trying
to tape the doll back together with
masking tape i mean obviously
metaphorically you know his masking tape
is not gonna hold off like all this
[ __ ] horror and everything like that
but that's like all she's got to uh to
to use like to do that so it's just kind
of like papering over the cracks sort of
thing and like i said while all this is
going on too there's like some
ridiculous [ __ ] where at some point uh
in the movie
she finally sees um you know pretty
incontrovertible proof that there is
like this evil
gin like floating around their [ __ ]
apartment and it freaks her out so she
picks up her little girl and runs the
[ __ ] out of the apartment like a smart
person would do then she gets um
taken to the police because she doesn't
have a head covering on and they
basically tell her well
you know a woman should be more afraid
of like being exposed than anything else
even though there's a [ __ ] evil gin
in her building so like i said that is
kind of like a backdrop of the whole
stuff that's going on like the whole
iran iraq war
and all the [ __ ] that happened
subsequently so it's bad enough she has
to deal with that but then she also has
to deal with uh you know her more
personal problems and [ __ ] like that so
i don't want to spoil too much about it
because i don't know if a lot of people
have seen this i feel like it got a lot
of attention because i think it
premiered at sundance it might have
gotten like kind of a brief theatrical
run i think not here but like in big
cities and then netflix picked it up
like not too long after that because i'm
pretty sure it's been on netflix maybe
like a year because i'm pretty sure i
watched it in like summer 2017 or
something like that like not that long
after it came out as far as i know as of
this recording it's still on netflix
right now
so
if you really like stuff like um you
know i hate to say it again but if you
really like the babadook if you really
liked um the devil's backbone uh this
kind of gave me a little bit of that
sort of vibe too like thematically um
you know not so much visually or
anything like that but this is very much
like
a really creepy
ghost story and like i said it's not
and there are like some jump scares and
stuff like that and the creepy [ __ ]
doesn't really start happening until the
halfway point but i really liked like
the domestic drama
and you know the backdrop of war like
behind it and like
and i really got into like she day's
character of like you know holy [ __ ]
like the whole country's changing like
all my rights are being taken away and
now i have to like deal with this kid
and now there's a [ __ ] evil gin in
here and
you know all this other kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's gotta deal with and like i
said i like i thought it was a brave
decision to make her
i'm not gonna say she's unlikable but
sometimes she's very prickly you know
what i mean but
that said you can understand like why
she would be that way um you know even
though sometimes yeah you know yeah she
shouldn't have snapped at her kid like
that yeah she shouldn't have done that
and stuff like that but you can totally
understand why because she's just like
at the end of her [ __ ] rope right
because she's got like all kind of
problems
but yeah so if you like that kind of
like metaphorical horror this does have
like i said you know once you get past
the halfway point it does have like some
really creepy imagery and like i said i
really love the image of the ghost like
wearing the chat or and it's like
there's one scene that's [ __ ] great
where she like reaches under the bed
because she thinks her daughter is under
there and then like she pulled and it's
and it's not her daughter um but i mean
it's really good like the the visual is
really good but yeah so if you haven't
seen it it's on netflix it came out in
2016. it's really cool because you don't
see i don't you know i don't i don't see
a lot of middle eastern horror a lot of
horror coming out of iran um so and i
mean i know that he moved to britain
like when he was a teenager so yeah he
actually like got but they didn't
actually even they couldn't even shoot
this in iran i believe they shot it in
jordan
but um but yeah so you don't really see
a lot of horror movies set like during
this time period or during this you know
in that area and so it's like really
cool to see
what is essentially like a haunted house
or like a ghost story like set against
that backdrop set against that cultural
framework so it's like really really
cool to see
that because you don't really see it all
that much but yeah definitely definitely
check it out if you're looking for
something a little bit different but
like i said that said it's not that
different it's you know it's
it's still pretty it's it's still like a
good ghost story uh you know with
metaphorical elements to it and a lot of
like family drama
kind of underlying it um but if it
sounds like your cup of tea i definitely
do recommend it um it was one of my
favorite uh horror movies from the past
several years i just really really liked
it a lot and i was really glad that i
got to watch it again because like i
said first time i watched it it was
dubbed and i don't recommend that i
don't really recommend watching anything
dubbed i mean you know it's
that's just me i don't really like
watching stuff dubbed but it's much
better when it's not dubbed because at
least that's what their real voices
sound like but yeah so yeah it's on
netflix under the shadow definitely
check it out um it's a great great ghost
story and i really dug it so that will
do it for this flickers of fear i will
see you guys on the next one
bye